the transformation is extraordinary in
here and a bit like keeping the accent
up all the time you did you keep the
teeth in all the time yeah I had his
teeth in because he has a over by a
massive over by which he never wanted to
mess with because he has four octave
range that he said I'm not screwing with
this ball I had these teeth made I was
like you I enjoyed it so much I'm not a
method actor I'm a method actor so let's
stop talking down method acts no problem
with it I'm just saying I'm not I've
worked with I've worked with method
actors that I absolutely adore and we
can go on about that I'll tell you about
this I cut my teeth in because I never
get a chance to end every sentence with
darling and dear and Freddie does and
that's quite nice it's nice it's nice
being I'd rather be Freddie Mercury for
most of the day than be Rami maja
by that and I appreciate it we was
bitching the the title of the film
Bohemian Rhapsody and it is such an
iconic Queen track as well as that
incredibly famous image you all know the
the thing and we thought because there
are four of us how hard could it be to
recreate this how well you two just need
to sit where you want go you need to get
in here just crouch a little bit and you
have wigs and stuff well if you want a
wig I've got I mean do you bow mr.
doback you don't you don't need a week I
could use no I don't want the wig no for
about six months
[Applause]
good now I have to do this okay you just
stare straight ahead at number seven
yeah okay we already live seven okay are
we singing bass I'm gonna start that
straight ahead straight ahead down seven
yeah okay here we go and change the
riding
[Applause]
[Music]
you